CHRIS WILCOX: Hey, Martin.
You brought a map.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah, Chris.
I just came back from a hike,
which I logged in the app
Take a Hike.
They built a system for
logging your hikes online.
It is serverless, and
exposes data from a Cloud SQL
database as a REST API.
CHRIS WILCOX: In a
previous episode,
we showed how one can
build serverless REST APIs.
In this episode, we'll
see how they made sure
that each user can only
access their own logged hikes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER:
Ana is a developer
working for Take a Hike, a
service for logging your hikes.
She built a REST API to enable
users to track their activity
from a web and mobile app.
CHRIS WILCOX: It turns out
it's quite easy to build
a REST API in Cloud Run.
As a bonus, Cloud
Run is serverless,
so there are no
servers to manage.
And Take a Hike will only pay
per-call with no fixed costs.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ana built
the REST API in Cloud Run
as a proof of concept.
Now that it's working well,
she needs to address security.
A user should only be
able to view and edit
their own hikes, not
those of other users.
CHRIS WILCOX:
Ana's first thought
is that the server would
send the user's ID to the web
client.
When that user logs
in, the web client
would then send the user's
ID back to the server
when accessing the REST API.
MARTIN OMANDER: But
there is a problem.
Ana remembers that one
cannot trust code running
on the client.
A malicious user could
modify the client code
so it sends a different
user ID than the one it
received from the server.
We're back where we started--
any client can read
any recorded hike.
CHRIS WILCOX: Ana does some
research and finds technology
that might help--
JSON Web Tokens, or JWTs.
When the client app logs
in, it gets the user ID
from the server
signed by the server.
MARTIN OMANDER:
The client app then
attaches the JSON
Web Token to any REST
call it makes to the server.
But Ana wonders, is there a
way to stop a malicious user
from modifying this token?
CHRIS WILCOX: As part
of the JWT standard,
the server signs all
tokens digitally.
If the client app
modifies the token
and sends it back to
the server, the server
will know that it was tampered
with and can refuse the call.
MARTIN OMANDER: This
means that Ana's code
that runs on the server
can trust the user
ID it gets from the client.
She can use that user
ID in her SQL code
when looking up the
user's recorded hikes.
CHRIS WILCOX: This sounds
great in principle,
but would it be hard for
Ana to write this code?
She doesn't have any
experience with cryptography.
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah.
Whenever you write
security-related code
like this, it's best to lean
on well-tested libraries.
If Ana does that,
there's less risk
of leaving a security hole open.
Fortunately, she doesn't have
to create the JSON Web Token.
Google's servers do that.
And when she decodes
the token, she
can use a library
provided by Google.
CHRIS WILCOX: This
is really cool.
What does the code look like?
MARTIN OMANDER: Tune
into a future episode
and we'll see Ana's code.
CHRIS WILCOX: Hey, Martin,
where do you hike to?
MARTIN OMANDER: Uh, I walked
over to the refrigerator.
CHRIS WILCOX:
Well, I suppose you
can take a long hike next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]